[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
doors I first think that Dear John and
Hank it's a comedy podcast about death
where my brother John and I we answer
your questions we give you dubious
advice and we bring you all of the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon John
I was wondering how you're doing uh you
know I'm doing really well mostly
because of the news from AFC Wimbledon
but I'm also doing terribly because I
just have gotten out of the dentist's
office like I have just risen from the
dentist's chair as I am recording this
and I am in terrible terrible pain in my
lower jaw did they let you cast do they
let you do the pod from the dentist's
office that's nice of them no I mean I
then I then drove to work and you know
now I'm here but yeah I I cannot
recommend this all started as you know
Hank many many years ago like eighteen
years ago when I was hit by a bike
messenger on the streets of Chicago his
shoulder into my jaw and nose and Here I
am eighteen years later still being I
mean I was in tears I am NOT I am NOT a
brave man and when it comes to dentistry
still suffering trying to get this
problem solved once and for all but
hopefully we're only one dental visit
away but then again it's far too soon to
count the chickens they have not yet
hatched how are you good I want to ask
you a quick question answer what answer
might one of my questions John if you
could had the opportunity to meet that
bike messenger would you and if so what
would you say I mean the thing is I
really I genuinely don't hold it against
the bike messenger because I think that
that bike messenger was forced by the
nature of his profession to be going the
wrong way down a one-way street at great
speed and to be fair to him I was
standing on the curb and he had to bike
because of where the cars were very near
the curb and he just didn't notice me I
was reading a book he was you know
biking his shoulder my face the one
thing I do kind of wish is that maybe
he'd stopped he did stop briefly I lost
consciousness for a good
a bit and when I regained consciousness
I did see him but the moment I started
to get up he biked away it was like well
I didn't kill him let's move on yeah it
wasn't I mean I I honestly don't bear
him any ill will it's just funny
what's that great Fitzgerald lying about
you never know how much space you take
up in other people's lives like that
bike messenger has no idea how central
he has become to my personal narrative
oh man yeah you never know you never
know I'm doing good John it's beautiful
I'm home in Montana it's gorgeous
my wife is very ill not very it not on
the way that that that makes that sound
but she's sick and and I'm taking care
of her and and I am I'm a pretty happy
camper aside from that I got a lot of
stuff to do but I'm not I'm gonna stop
saying that on the pod John because I
keep saying it and I think it makes me
sound like a broken record a little bit
and also I could like a bit of a douche
I don't want to always be like I'm so
busy I'm a busy man you know the problem
with being busy a very busy man job back
when I lived in Chicago I would often
think about this because I would see
business people in suits rushing to the
Train as if you know their time was was
fundamentally more important than my
time and as if they're like three
minutes they might save was going to
make a big difference to the rest of
their day mm-hmm and even if that's true
you're correct that it comes across as
douchey that's why I never run to the
Train in fact that's why I never run you
run all the time you are an exercising
fool Hank would you like a short poem
for today oh okay let's do it write this
poem is by Francis Darwin Cornford who
Hank you'll be pleased to know was a
granddaughter of Charles Darwin himself
oh this poem is called on Rupert Brooke
Rupert Brooke was a world war one poet
who died in World War one
a young Apollo golden haired Stan's
dreaming on the verge of strife
magnificently unprepared for the long
littleness of life hmm
the long littleness of life one of the
the great phrases about human existence
I've ever come across that poem was
recommended by Sam so thank you Sam
by the way Hank Frances Cornford husband
was named guests ah Charles Darwin
rancis corn Ford Oh interesting it was
Francis and Francis I would have been
funny if it had been Charles Darwin and
she just kept her maiden name instead of
going back to her hurled that's what I
was hoping for but I was wrong that guy
you know maybe would have been my next
guest John if you had asked again did
you know that you know what you want to
know what Frances corn Ford's father's
name was Francis corn Ford no Francis
Darwin of course because he was a Darwin
Oh
let's move on to some questions from our
listeners I want to say first John did
you know that that the god Apollo was
born in a place I did not I just I think
that's very strange like the whole the
Oh like panoply they like the Greek god
stuff it's all it's all fascinating to
me and I think we understand it
improperly in some ways because we are
we are not of that world and so we we
read and think about these things in our
inside of our own frameworks and the
idea that and I only recently I don't
know why I learned this but I was like
it was like ah this city in Greece the
birthplace of Apollo and I was like
Apollo gods don't get born but of course
they do because it's a different kind of
thing and that's all I wanted to say
John is it time for other things if it's
time for questions so it's not something
that we do I think we should I think we
should go ahead and address some of the
questions our listeners have sent us via
the email address Hank and John at
gmail.com okay let's do that we have one
here
it's from Foster and I like this
question a lot who asks it's kind of a
Hank question but I think you can weigh
in as well dear Hank and John according
to the dictionary a desert is quote a
region so arid because of so little
rainfall that it supports only sparse
and widely spaced vegetation or no
vegetation at all does that make outer
space a desert yes that's what I'm gonna
say I'm gonna say yes what do you think
John I agree I mean it's the desert east
desert of all because the vegetation is
as far as we know it
you know a sparse like in the exception
is the big massive universe there is
just the one locale with vegetation that
we know of that we know certainly and
even if there are even if there are
millions of of spots of vegetation they
are sparse they are spaced apart yeah
and and it's interesting to think of the
amount of rainfall in space but in a way
rain does fall at least precipitation
does fall from space we know that earth
and and other other planets are seeded
with water from comets that that crashed
down on earth and that's part of the
reason why we've been able to maintain
the amount of water that we have on
earth throughout the last four billion
years and so in that way it kind of does
rain on these little oases of vegetation
at least in our solar system and I yeah
and and deserts were always kind of seen
as you know you can think of them like
oceans in ancient times because it was
so difficult to cross them that they
were basically like whatever's going on
on the other side of that desert has
nothing to do with us and kind of never
will and and and in that same way outer
space is our desert right now it is the
inhospitable place that we still cannot
cross and that and and will remain that
way at least until we get our butts to
Mars John which is also a desert well I
for one hope that we never begin to
cross the desert of outer space because
from what I can tell from soap operas
set in space that's what all the trouble
so well there's soap operas here on
earth too John we start trouble
everywhere we go alright Nick we have
another question this one comes from
Isis who writes Dear John and Hank my
name is Isis which is sort of the
problem I'm named after an Egyptian
goddess but ever since the Salafi
jihadist militant group started gaining
more media attention my name is viewed
from a very different perspective
every time I introduced myself to
someone new I'm scared for their
reaction while a lot of people are aware
of my struggle there are still people
who like to joke about my name and
people tend to associate it with
something negative and I don't know how
to deal with this do you have any advice
lots of love
Isis PS maybe I should consider
changing my name to Ryan first off Isis
that is a fantastic idea let's just uh
I'm surprised that we keep getting
questions from not Ryan I it's upsetting
it's weird I in fact Hank this week we
didn't get a single question from Ryan
which is so odd because everyone should
have changed their name to Ryan with his
podcast obvious maybe they just haven't
maybe they just haven't gotten the memo
yet but Isis I think the correct
decision here is to abandon your name
your family heritage and your parents
and change your name to Ryan
no I don't think that's the correct
solution at all I want to point out here
that Isis has put the word struggle in
quotation marks so Isis is aware that
this is yes yeah IIIi don't want I want
everyone to know that yeah no I think
Isis is aware that it is a problem of
you know limited import but still
significant to Isis yes that blows is
that are we allowed to say that word I'm
sorry I think we are allowed to say that
something blows but only if we then say
chunks I think that blows chunks Isis I
apologize for the structure of the
universe that that this unusual thing
has happened to yeah but at the same
time I think it's important not to let
Isis hijack your name yeah you've got to
continue being Isis and explain over and
over and over again as annoying as it
might be that you were named after an
Egyptian goddess not after a recently
formed jihadist yeah but what I what I
mean when I with from my previous
comment is that we will all be in
circumstances in our lives to greater or
lesser extents that are unusual
surprising weird coincidences that we
think why has this happened to me but
it's because there are so many of them
that we are bound to have one of these
weird unfortunate things happen to us
and this is one of the ones that has
happened to you Isis and and when they
happen the thing to do is just live your
life despite it yeah I mean the only
alternative is to start going by a
nickname which i think is fine if you
want to like I don't think there's
anything wrong with I don't think you'd
like to this is necessarily the
that one has to fight and die on if you
want to start going by a nickname I
think that you should feel feel welcome
to and if you do choose to start going
by a nickname might I suggest Ryan
alright job we got another one this one
is from RJ who asks dear Hank and John
I'm a biology teacher in Texas where we
give a standardized test every year from
the state while I'm proctoring this test
I cannot read grade papers playing
lessons work on my computer or otherwise
do anything except stare at the students
as they sweat it out for sometimes up to
five hours if I break these rules I
could lose my teaching license any
dubious advice on how I can pass the
time without being bored to death would
be much appreciated oh I don't know just
burn it all to the ground that sounds
awful
yeah and spend that whole five hours
fantasizing about a world in which we
find ways to measure educational
outcomes other than standardized tests
that require such dedication to the
prevention of cheating that that we
require someone to be paid I what I hope
is a fair wage to sit and do nothing
my first response is just that I'm
fascinated by your use of the phrase
bored to death and I think there's
something worth unpacking there like
David Foster Wallace wrote in The Pale
King if can I read you a quote Hank oh
of course you can
maybe dullness is associated with
psychic pain because something that's
dull or opaque fails to provide enough
stimulation to distract people from some
other deeper type of pain that is always
there if only in an ambient low-level
way and which most of us spend nearly
all our time and energy trying to
distract ourselves from feeling or at
least from feeling directly or with our
full attention and maybe that's like
what's so utterly horrifying about the
prospect of spending five hours doing
nothing except sort of being alone with
your own thoughts is that the for me at
least like the thought of being alone
with my thoughts is rather terrifying
right I get that at the same time like
we're not all Buddhist monks and maybe
RJ is perfectly well-adjusted and fine
with being alone in thinking in silence
sometimes but not for five straight
hours
consistently several times through the
year like I don't know that's just once
a year is that is it I don't know well
that's what it says it just says once a
year once a year is not so bad to spend
five hours alone with your thoughts
unless there's something terrifying
inherently about being alone with your
thoughts which I think there is because
I think the thing that it raises the
gleich question that it raises at least
for me when I spend an extended period
of time just thinking is that I am not
actually in control of these thoughts
like I don't actually decide what to
think about which is truly like a horror
movie right like if you're stuck inside
of a consciousness but you cannot shape
the directions in which it goes you are
kind of like a protagonist in a horror
film okay at the same time I mean maybe
maybe maybe there is a fundamental like
problem with this board but that that's
beyond just the nothing to do that is
the the the being inside of a brain that
one cannot control that that seems to me
I'm just going to disagree with you and
I think that it's fine that we disagree
that seems to me to just not doesn't
have to be a deep philosophical problem
it could just be like I'm bored and this
sucks and that's okay that's how I feel
we could differ and but I I don't really
have any any solution for Rjay though
which is what he's asking for not not a
clinical diagnosis so not I'm not trying
to diagnose anybody with anything I'm
just telling RJ that he is not alone in
not wanting to be alone with this not
for five hours in fact I think it's
pretty much a universal human yes and
and and the people who can do it and I
and end like spending time even even
like five minutes meditating can be very
difficult with and and my my mind is
always racing and always doing things
and even if even if I'm sitting there
doing absolutely nothing that doesn't
mean that I'm paying attention to these
students I could be in another
world right idea that I can't be
listening to a podcast while I'm
watching these kids is ridiculous
because there's whether or not I'm
listening to a podcast there's a podcast
in my brain and I could be on planet Z
like I am not there and I'm I'm just as
oblivious sitting in my chair staring
into the the darkness of my own psyche
as I am listening to Hank and John Green
talk about the darkness of my own psyche
right now so I think this is a dumb rule
the more Jay should be allowed to listen
to a podcast specifically because
there's a great podcast he should be
listening to and he's listening to it
right now hi RJ I was gonna recommend my
brother my brother and me but I guess
this one's all right the only thing that
I would say in the way of real actual
advice RJ is that when I was a kid and
to some extent still now I I had this
trick that I used to distract myself
when I had to be alone with my thoughts
which was that I just doubled numbers so
I would say 2 4 8 16 32 64 128 256 512
1024 2048 4000 192 8300 we get it John
you know a lot of numbers and then I
would just keep going until I couldn't
go anymore and then I would just I got
to the point where I would have to add
very slowly in my head which is a great
distraction let's move on Hank I think
we've spent 45 minutes answering this
question maybe it's time to move on to a
different one that's probably pretty
good idea we got one John it's from
Jackie can I do another one today should
I do another one right now I feel like
yours to go in a row okay it's from
Jackie and I love this question too
because it lets me talk about snapchat
dear Hank and John I'm on the older side
of the generation sometimes called
Millennials and I feel like I'm unique
in the fact that I just don't get
snapchat it's in all caps I have one but
I don't use it I got bored what's so
great about it why not just use
Instagram Oh Jackie you're so confused
well I think the reason not to use
Instagram is because snapchat embraces
the temporariness of human existence in
a way that Instagram doesn't well I mean
yeah Instagram is like snapchat ism is
primarily a messaging app which is not
what Instagram is at all you know
snapchat has become also a social app
but it started out as a message
so just like me sending you basically a
text and this is the thing that I didn't
understand about snapchat when I first
heard about it when I'm sending you a
snapchat like I sent snapchats to my
wife even as a 35 year old man which is
weird I will be doing something that I
know she will know that I spent some
time on so I take a picture I draw in
the picture and I leave a little note
and I'm like I wanted you to see this
thing and that's like it's like a new
form of greeting card it's like a way of
like spending some time making a thing
for a person which is like I think it's
lovely of course that other person has
to be on and active on snapchat in order
to get and appreciate that message but I
think that's a lot of the reason why
people do it and also this feature of
the temporariness of the snapchat as an
object seems to you know my brain
initially to be a bug not a feature like
I want all things to last forever so
that I don't lose the things that
construct me because losing those things
is kind of like little deaths all the
time and I don't want to lose those
things because I want to continue to
keep all those parts of me alive but for
someone who's been raised in a world
where all things always last forever
that can be terrifying and it's
wonderful to think that you can create
something and then it will go away and
you don't feel worried about it being a
part of who you are forever
you can change in people who are young
change very fast and and they kind of
don't necessarily want those parts of
themselves that are that that like that
are representative of who they were once
to be representative of who they are
forever and that's a very understandable
thing to me that and that to me is the
is the sort of core functionality of
snapchat and how most people use it
which is not mostly how I use it I use
it as a way to interact with an audience
because I have I enjoyed that answer and
I don't want to add to it because I
think that this might be one of the few
episodes where you talk more than me so
instead we're just gonna move on to
another question from Matt writes Dear
John and Hank loved the podcast
thank you Matt I have I have real
trouble dealing with laughs that are
just too far over the top make me think
that nothing can possibly be that funny
I find it very hard to concentrate or
enjoy myself when
and over-the-top laugher how do you deal
with this well Matt fortunately I don't
have to because I myself am an
over-the-top laugher and so I don't even
know what it's like not to be one as am
i we just aren't gonna hang out you and
you and me Matt it's just not gonna work
out between us do you like this podcast
I feel like we over-the-top laugh all
the time
heyo I so I went to a play recently that
my friend that wolf was in who's also in
the movies Paper Towns in The Fault in
Our Stars and a bright as soon as the
play ended I got a text from NAT that
said it just said I could hear your
laugh the whole time and I was like I
was like it's not that loud it's not
that loud of a laugh and he was like I
could hear your laugh and only your
laugh and it was almost impossible to be
in the play and not be like that is Jon
laughing I I once watched a movie in a
small movie theater like a little
independent movie theater and then
afterward a woman came up to me and she
said I think your laugh is lovely
[Laughter]
compliments on my life I just get
observations about it yeah yeah well
that's the Oh literally the only time
but I was I was very pleased and and it
made me feel good because I don't like I
like Matt I do worry that that the
people around you will will notice and
and laugh less and I think that laughing
is one of the best things and so I I
worry about the potential effect that
you or your opinions of laughter might
have on the people around you and make
them laugh less because they're worried
they're self-conscious about their
laughter which I I never want anyone to
be yeah I have one friend who has what
seems to me a weird laugh and I can't
help but notice it whenever they laugh
I'm not even going to risk gender
identifying them for fear that they will
know about this and be devastated and I
know that I have that laugh for a lot of
people like I know a lot of people are
like oh my god like he's a nice guy but
that laugh is he kidding yeah no I'm not
kidding I'm just in love with the world
I know now we're both so so I have this
problem when I edit myself when I edit
like especially conversations I will you
know when I'm just being normal Hank and
right now I'm sort of being podcast Hank
so I have more of a robust laugh but
like normal Hank laugh is very like
especially if it's sort of it's just
like laughing at the the fun little
parts of a conversation that aren't
super funny you're just sort of like
you're reacting is very it's like a
wheezy noise it's like like that that I
just hate and I always do it on top of
people's sentences so it's very
difficult to edit the video because I'm
happy to hear this like weird we don't
begin as soon as it's time for for like
right before the end of their sentence
and then you think like well I guess I
just need to keep the laugh in because
otherwise people won't will be confused
by what that we's is but like I hate the
laugh and also it's an unnecessary three
seconds in the video I can totally
relate to that which has nothing to do
with Matt's question no it are so far
off the rails
sure are we can say Matt is that you you
just judge silently always he is okay
it's okay to be a silent judge or it's
better than being a loud judge her put
it on a shirt but that one on a shirt uh
if we have another question Hank this
one comes from gypsy who asks Dear John
and Hank I have a beautiful gray hound
named Alaska I adopted her because of
lemon and hex videos on I adopted her
because of lemon and Hanks video on
saving greyhounds all Hank that's so
sweet and I did it she falls asleep as
soon as I start playing your podcast
your voices must be very soothing for
her she howls and cries whenever we
leave the house so I was thinking if I
could play your podcast for her while
we're gone it might calm her down how do
you suggest I do this as I cannot
obviously leave my phone at home playing
it and I don't have an iPod and she'll
definitely destroy my laptop if it's
left out do you have any suggestions yes
gypsy I have a solution that suits both
of us very very well which is that Hank
and I would like to send you an iPod in
exchange for you playing our podcast on
a loop over and over to your greyhound
which will be great for our download
numbers and great for your Greyhound and
third great for you because free iPod so
write us at Hank and John at gmail.com
we'll get you an iPod Oh dad we're
giving away iPods now John no just that
one
just just one and only because the
person agreed to listen to our podcast
over and over or at least have her dog
listen okay I love it I love it we got
another question this is from Sarah John
you want to hear a question from Sarah
yes she asks dear Hank and John I find
myself in awkward situations quite often
but there is always one that seems to be
recurring when people compliment me
that's interesting that you say that
it's recurring people compliment me so
often I just don't know what to do
I always seem to just smile and nod
along with and awkwardly laugh how is
someone supposed to respond to
compliments do I compliment back please
help well I was just talking about this
time that a woman came up to me in
public and complimented me on my laugh
and she was a stranger and and that was
well into my history with figuring out
how to deal with this because I used to
suck at it a lot and I think that there
is there is kind of a problem with the
way that we are taught to respond to
compliments which is just just basically
say no I'm not that great
and oh basically invalidate their
opinion by saying like you're wrong I'm
nothing special right what you want to
do instead is you want to acknowledge
the compliment and share with the person
who complimented you how it made you
feel so some way of saying you know
thanks that's very that's very kind or
thanks you know I really needed that
today I don't think it makes sense to
respond immediately with a compliment of
your own because it's weird right so
like like for instance if someone says
to you oh my gosh I love that Doctor Who
t-shirt you could say thank you what you
don't want to say is thank you I love
your scarf because if you say I love
your scarf it's good we all know what
you're doing there yeah right like that
isn't that isn't born of a natural love
for the scarf it's born of like a
panicked looking at the person and
trying to identify something
a compliment about them and all when you
say I love your scarf all it makes me
think is oh wow every other part of me
must be totally reprehensible because
this person needed to find a complement
and the only thing they could find was
my scarf though you can compliment them
on their compliment by saying something
like oh I love Doctor Who do you also
love Doctor Who I find that great people
love Doctor Who or thanks for saying
that it's always it's I really
appreciate people who take the time to
say nice things to people like that sort
of thing like like like I like the idea
of appreciating people's appreciation
and because I think that that breathes
more and I think that appreciation is
one of the vital currencies of human
interaction that is in demand and in
short supply hey good luck that we've
gone back to agreeing after our brief
fight over the the deadliness of boredom
goofus I'm really glad that we've gone
back to just the old-school Hank and
John always on the same page business
speaking of which but to us let's answer
I was just gonna say I think we should
disagree more there has to be some
tension in the pond but unfortunately I
just don't often disagree with you at
least not about important things I
disagree with you about silly things
like you know zombies versus unicorns or
whether Batman is an interesting
superhero but we don't disagree about
like the core deep down stuff I think
possibly because we were raised by the
same parents right like snapchat we
agree on snapchat I do I like snapchat
more than I used to because I now
understand it to be a messaging app not
a social media app and I like it
you know like Sarah and I have also
started using it and it is it's it's
like a sweet way to as you said like
make a greeting card so i am i would say
40% converted to snapchat but in general
I have to say that I find my overall
interest in virtual experiences and
virtual networks to have declined in the
last year yeah for the first time in my
whole life I mean since I was you know
12 and my dad brought home the Internet
I have liked the internet more every
year until last year and that's kind of
a distressing turn of events in my own
life but I'll get over okay well you
should make a video about that I'd love
to hear more and I I I'm I'm kind of
there with you I don't know how to make
a video about it though I don't know how
to talk about it but you don't and
almost I think it's very sad it I'm
gonna seem ungrateful and I think if I
talk about it honestly like I'm gonna
seem yeah I'm gonna seem like the kind
of person I don't want to be which maybe
I am I don't know but I iiiii don't
think I'm settled enough to make a video
about it instead I think I'm gonna make
tomorrow's video about how Looking for
Alaska was just announced as the most
challenged book of last year by the
American Library Association but Panama
papers John I need you to explain it to
me I was gonna make a video about how to
make a million dollars a year and only
pay forty five thousand dollars in taxes
but then it proved to be so complicated
that I gave up on the Panama papers are
complicated because corporate law is
intentionally complicated because yes
that's how tax avoidance basically at
its core works is by being too complex
to effectively unravel and so trying to
make a video about it is just completely
overwhelming to me and I'm working like
day and night on my novel and so I don't
really have a ton of energy to spend on
the Panama papers but I hope you make a
video about it I would greatly enjoy
your take it's not gonna happen cuz I
got a lot of other stuff to do I'll see
you there and we're both in the same
boat let's answer one more question
before we get to the all-important news
from AFC Wimbledon and these slightly
important news from Mars okay John do I
have one that I've wanted to ask since
the beginning but I haven't got to yet
sure this is a more serious question
John
it's from Margaret who asks dear Hank
and John I'm in a rather dire need of
some dubious advice I'm very passionate
about gymnastics I practice four hours a
day and six days per well but I have
recently fractured my spine and even
though it now heal and it's not as
threatening as it sounds I have to take
six months off I'm pretty devastated and
I was wondering what you think are good
ways to find joy and happiness
and purpose when I could not do what I
want to be doing this is something I
think about a lot because I I'm also a
dedicated gymnast not actually I am
cannot touch my toes but I am worried
that the thing that I love and want to
do will somehow be taken away from me
whether that's because it will just
become like the this thing will become
less interesting culturally whether
that's the pod or it's the the videos or
because like some terrible thing will
happen to my life where I can't do it
anymore
so I I do think about this do you want
to talk about it John or should just die
well I have actually had a little bit of
direct experience in the field without
being like overly dramatic
after my book The Fault in Our Stars
came out the like attention and a wide
readership and success of it was so
overwhelming and paralyzing to me that
it became totally impossible to write
which I had never been a problem in my
life and I'd always made fun of writer's
block and and it wasn't that I it wasn't
that I couldn't you know write words
down on a page it was that I couldn't
have the experience of writing that I
loved which was this experience of sort
of being alone inside of a story
navigating my way through it feeling
like I wasn't stuck inside of my body or
myself and all of that was taken away
from me because I was just so hyper
conscious of the audience and what
people would think and what people would
say and and the fact that I might have
to publish it someday and I couldn't get
that stuff out of my head and I think
that that's a pretty common problem
among writers who have successful books
and a lot of times it's the end of you
know it's the end of their career like
for a couple writers come to mind JD
Salinger never wrote a novel after
Catcher in the Rye and Harper Lee never
wrote a novel after to kill a
mockingbird and I think it was really
hard it was it was a bad time in my life
and it's only really just ended in the
last 10 months or so and what I did and
what I would recommend you do Margaret
is I found other stuff that I liked
doing and I tried to tree
this setback as an opportunity to
explore those things so I couldn't write
and that sucked and I had you know
written really every pretty much every
day since 2002
and I couldn't do that but I could do
other stuff that I liked doing that's a
lot of where the initial energy behind
crash course world history came for me a
lot of energy behind the podcast came
for me lots of other things too I just
had to find other things that I liked
doing and and get excited about them yes
and I'm sure that there are those things
in your life whether it's reading or
writing you know fan fiction about
Chewbacca and Han Solo having a romantic
relationship whatever it is that you
just find that stuff and you celebrate
it and get excited about it and sort of
use that as a focus for your energy
until you can get back to training yeah
I that is a lot of exactly what I wanted
to say Jon you we agree too much and you
also say that in general when we
dedicate ourselves to things day and day
out it can and those things then you
know temporarily or forever go away that
can seem like a tremendous end and that
and almost like a waste like we've spent
all of this time doing this thing that
we can no longer do but while you know
there are certainly things that you have
learned while doing gymnastics that
aren't directly applicable to other
stuff there are lots of things that we
when we dedicate ourselves to anything
that we learn that will be very
applicable to anything else and like
things like how to how to you know
control yourself how to dedicate
yourself how to get excited how to
interact with other people how to you
know like the self control is just a
huge thing in all of our lives and will
always be and obviously something that
you have you have found a way to to get
at and and I think that's that's the
important thing like that you find other
ways you know in this six months and in
the future when you are no longer doing
gymnastics because that's not ten
doesn't tend to be something that people
do for their whole lives
you find ways to dedicate yourself in
like find those same wells of passion
for new things and and and find ways to
apply the skills that you have learned
to the new things that you are into and
I'm sorry to hear about your injury and
I hope that you recover quickly and this
podcast is brought to you by the rapid
recovery of Margaret the the rapid
recovery of Margaret hopefully six
months or less and this podcast is also
brought to you by over-enthusiastic
laughter judging silently judging
silently the correct response to over
enthusiastic laughter and of course this
podcast is brought to you by boredom
boredom the closest thing we have to
understanding death itself ah the
unavoidable darkness inside of all of us
and I also want to say this podcast is
brought to you by our supporters on
patreon if you want to go there and
participate in the community we also do
a monthly livestream before we record so
that we can talk a little bit with y'all
and those are always really fun I tends
to be the first Tuesday of the month and
is that right John I think it's I don't
know but can I say one more thing about
Margaret though but yes thank you to our
patreon subscribers you know what I was
I was just thinking you love gymnastics
but that doesn't mean you are gymnastics
and a lot of times those two ideas get
kind of commingled in our heads like I
mean for me specifically as a writer you
know mm-hmm in a way you are you're
writing because I say I say out loud I
am a writer or I am a gymnast which I'm
not and that makes you think of it as
not just something that you love but
something that's that's you and when
that's taken away it feels like you have
lost you but you haven't of course
because you are a gymnast but you're
also of course many other things and I
would just encourage you to remember
yeah absolutely we got some news from
from Mars John if you're interested in
that yeah I wanted to do a couple quick
updates Hank if we could Oh about other
things besides Mars and AFC what just
previous things that we talked about on
the podcast first off I just wanted to
say Ryan's name a couple times Ryan Ryan
and then the other thing is that Oriana
wrote in and I thought this was a really
interesting comment because when we were
talking about drive through drive-thrus
and who like should be allowed to use
the drive-through lane and the fact that
we think that like families with ten
children should be allowed to use the
drive-through lane because it's such a
pain to unhook your kids from their car
seats Oriana wrote in and she made a
great observation which is that we were
thinking about that only from the
perspective of the people using the
drive-through lane she writes near John
and Hank we need to talk about drive
throughs and your recent comments on
them I'm an university student who
supports herself by working part-time
during the school year at an
establishment which includes a drive
through drive-thrus are supposed to be
fast way to be event so this is so much
the case that most corporate fast food
businesses impose mandatory drive
through time standards where I work at
peak hours were allotted a maximum
average of 50 seconds for the entire
process of ordering paying and receiving
food there's a timer over the window
that counts as the person sits there
trying to find their change and begins
to have read after 20 seconds if people
sit at the speaker thinking about what
they want for two minutes that counts
toward our times
if we don't consistently meet our
corporate standards our store risks
being shut down which makes owners come
down hard on managers and managers come
down hard on employees so if you have
ten children perhaps consider sending
one of the adults into the store to
purchase the food if this isn't an
option and you must come through the
drive-through at least figure out what
everyone wants before you pull up and
try to have your wallet out and your
payment ready when you get to the window
that's a great observation thank you
Oreo Wow I mean there is there is a
piece of me that is very frustrated with
the the established corporate structure
that should accept that there are places
and times wit and lots of families will
be going through the drive-thru and thus
there is a reason that has nothing to do
with employees why it is taken yeah but
that
said we live in the world in which we
live so if you're using a drive yet
remember Orianna bring your have your
payment and your order ready yes have
your payment in your order ready and
especially if you've got if there's a
line and it wouldn't what it amazes me
when I I feel like there's a line and
I've been waiting in the drive-through
for like six cars and then the car ahead
of me has like one person in it and then
they're they're clearly just thinking
and I'm like what are you thinking about
you've had you've had like 20 minutes to
decide there's a there's only so many
items on the menu all right I also want
to point out one other thing Hank Nicole
and Steven wrote in Dear John and Hank
on this week's podcast you mentioned
that your GPA and college does not
matter while this may be true for you it
is not true in certain fields which is a
really good point
they include medical school or other
specialized grad schools most PhD
programs especially in the sciences and
and if you apply for certain positions
in the scientific industry like doing
benchtop work at wet labs they look at
your lab GPA so sometimes your GPA in
college does matter yeah I've been
thinking about that question a lot
actually I have continued to think about
it and and and and I don't know that we
did the bet the best job of answering
that particular question which was about
whether like how frustrating it can be
to watch to struggle with work while
watching other people cheat and to get
good grades in college no I agree we
might have it we were pretty dubious
we're generally damn pious but we might
have put put it like a little bit of
dubious sauce on the dubious burger it
sounds delicious though can I get it
that's a that's a great point Nicole and
Stephen and I also just like theirs in
thinking about that question I have I've
continued to think that it is just so it
is always so difficult to feel like
direct injustice and and to know that
like this thing is happening and I'm
being negatively impacted by doing the
right thing yeah it is annoying yeah and
and I do want to I do want to
commiserate with people who are in in
those situations and certainly not
invalidate their feel I agree
Hank what is the week's news from Mars
so John you know uh how here on earth we
spend a lot of time you know you
particularly worrying about things that
could cause the destruction of the human
race like like asteroid impacts comet
impact that kind of thing you would say
I you know maybe that the impact of a
comet large comet the size of say West
Virginia or something that's pretty big
but we'll just say that would be a bad
thing for earth life on Earth right I
think it would be very bad so that would
be a very bad thing for life on Earth
however according to recent research the
the periods of time when lots of things
asteroids and comets bombarded early in
the the sort of formation of the solar
system bombarded Earth and Mars and a
lot of the inner planets and probably a
lot of the outer planets though there's
less evidence out there because they're
made of gas and created like all the
creators on the moon and a lot of
craters on Mars these periods of time
are thought of as hostile times right
but according to recent research it
looks like they might have been very
good times for life on Mars because in
addition to the the the constant
bombardment of and and the the changes
to the surface that this would create
the instability that would it would
create both on earth or earth and on
Mars it would add water and heat to Mars
which are two things that would be very
good for Mars in terms of being
habitable good for life and so you would
see things like sort of Yellowstone
National Park II areas places where
there's there's heat that could be used
for for life there's weird chemicals
that are forming and those chemicals
could be digested that they might
contain be formed because of the heat
and then as they cool off
they could be digested and and the
energy that was stored in them by the
heat could be used by organisms and so
you have these geothermal areas you have
more water and in general the best time
on Mars for life might have been those
periods of time which we would consider
the least
ha the least like sort of conducive to
life for Earth but indeed also may have
been good times for microbial life on
earth and more and more we're thinking
that Mars might have been a really good
place for microbial life just at this
point no longer one of one of the sort
of oases of the universe that Earth has
become where not just life exists but
life is on the life that is on the life
on the life there's so much life it's
everywhere and you can't get away from
it even even in your own body John
you're covered in love really especially
in your own body comfort in life both
inside and out it's like it's like just
a life what is it what is it like it's
like you're it's like you're a life
sandwich we're we're I I am the meat in
the middle and I got life on the inside
and outside of me you're more of a life
doughnut John okay let's get to the
newsroom AFC Wimbledon I am distressed
by the news from Mars so Hank you may
know that your six-year-old nephew Henry
my son is a soccer player he plays in a
Sid soccer league under sevens and he
had a game as it happened during the
exact same time his AFC Wimbledon's game
this weekend how am i good which made
for some very compelling watching on my
part Henry's team won he played great
and AFC Wimbledon playing Plymouth one
of the top five teams in week two was
winning one nil thanks to a goal from
the montserrat he and Messi that man
Lyle Taylor and then they gave up a goal
Plymouth is was heavily favored in the
game
and then it was looking like it was
going to be a 1-1 draw which did not
suit AFC Wimbledon's interests really at
all and then in the 88th minute Auto be
lock-in phenoix the largest man in
professional football scored a audible
aachen phenoix brilliant vintage goal
coming on as a substitute scores a goal
a AFC Wimbledon wins 2-1 and suddenly
finds themselves not in 10th where they
or last week but in seventh the final
playoff position seventh place goes into
the playoffs four five six seven all
play each other in the playoffs for one
spot in in League One the third tier of
English football and AFC Wimbledon are
currently sitting in that final playoff
position level on points with the teams
in eighth and ninth but with a better
goal difference and just two points
ahead of the teams in 10th and 11th and
only three points ahead of the team in
12th so they're basically a lot of teams
fighting for that final playoff spot
right now AFC Wimbledon is in the
driver's seat I would also add that they
have a game in hand having played one
less game than all the other teams that
are that are looking to get that final
playoff spot it is tense at the top Hank
it is very very tight AFC Wimbledon
having a far better season than anyone
anticipated I think it's safe to say and
and after that win consecutive wins
against Wickham and Plymouth both teams
likely to go to the playoffs it is well
I mean it's looking possible I'm
dreaming
that's exciting John I I cannot I am
very pleased that it had such an
exciting season for us to talk about
here on dear Hank and John because it
could easily have been super boring I
mean we're very lucky because most
seasons the season would be well over by
now or you know we'd be looking down at
the bottom of the table in true epic
fear yeah so how many games are there
left well that depends on which team you
are if you are any of AFC Wimbledon's
opponents there are six games five games
left and if you are AFC Wimbledon there
are six games left
so other than Portsmouth which is one
spot ahead of us on the table all the
teams that are likely to go to the
playoffs
have played 41 games we have only played
40 so it is it is tense and it is tight
according to bookies and like gambling
professionals AFC Wimbledon has about a
sixty six percent chance of going to the
playoffs which I mean again that
just be an amazing result for the year
but I am I am properly dreaming now I
have I have I have figured out how I am
going to get to the play-off final
should should they make it there Wow I'm
going to have to drive directly from the
Indianapolis 500 to the airport oh my
goodness they'd have to win the first
game and then go to the final after that
the first game is actually kind of a
home in a way it's two games so it's
like three that have score over those
two games you play one away and one at
home and then if you win though that
then you get to go to the playoff final
so you know it's it's there's a 66%
chance of AFC wimbledon having a 25%
chance of getting into week one so it's
not you know the odds are still stacked
well against them but I am oh hope is
the thing with feathers yes indeed yes
indeed congratulations John I'm excited
for you and even a little excited for
myself so that's saying something well
we learned that gypsies getting an iPod
that's what you get for adopting a
greyhound it's the only way to be a
truly good per to encourage people good
people and we learned that you can
accept compliments and that's a good
thing to do to appreciate other people's
appreciations even if it is difficult
because we are taught to be humble folk
we learned that you must have your order
and your method of payment ready when
you get to the drive-thru absolutely and
we learned that we are surrounded by an
infinite desert that is space is it
infinite and we're not sure John where
is problem it's there's a fair chance
145 percent chance that this is a 67
percent chance that it's yeah if AFC
Wimbledon make it to Ligue 1 I am
announcing that the universe is infinite
because how else could it have
yeah exactly I mean only only in an
infinite universe full of infinite
possibilities can a team like AFC
Wimbledon make it not to the 8th tier of
English football or even to the 4th tier
but to the third tier just two
promotions away from the Premier League
Hank oh man it's hard not to imagine a
day when the John Green stand is hosting
Manchester United fans but I see you
know John I think that that may be a
little out of your budget at that point
it probably will be but you know I have
an existing I have an existing
relationship well hopefully by then I'll
be super rich from having made the AFC
Wimbledon movie yeah that's where the
real money is all right John thank you
for being a podcaster with me I want to
thank all of the people for sending in
their questions which you can do you can
send them to Hank and John at gmail.com
we are also Hank green and John green on
Twitter you can find us there that's two
different Twitter handles not just the
one we have our patreon at patreon.com
slash dear Hank and John which helps pay
for our intern and and the editor of
this podcast and our intern is Claudia
Morales our editor is Nicholas Jenkins
rosianna halse rojas helps us find good
questions in the dear Hank and John
email address again Hank and John at
gmail.com our theme music is by
gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome did
I get to all the things you did but yeah
I forgot to say don't forget to be
awesome with you so we're gonna do it
again because that's how we go out oh I
did a poll I did it very either there
very poorly and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Applause]
you
[Music]